first of all I want to start with a
question that I have been curious about
how many of you came to react native
from native development please raise
your hand and how many from front-end
JavaScript
Wow fifty-fifty I guess I say oh good to
know
finally a real step so today we're going
to talk about how to implement those
graphics SVG graphics inside the react
native app so we're ready to talk about
SVG let's go for it so my name is ollie
I'm a software developer the company
called CAPRISA for the last year or so
we've been very busy doing react native
I'm gonna talk about it a little bit and
but before that I was busy doing
front-end development for a few years
and before that Android native
development so I kind of got the grass
for both worlds native in front-end if
you wanna look me up and social media
Twitter whatever this is my handle huh
one more tier I came from Israel which
is a pretty far away so quick note about
caprices company I work for
so CAPRISA the company and we made the
system called the proof simple which
consolidates approvals from various IT
system in an enterprise so we sell to
enterprises but we build an app from the
ground up in react native for the last
like six months this particular app we
built in the in the first three months
we got it up in up and ready in the App
Store and it all revolves around this
nice carousel so we had a lot of a lot
of good journey in with the flat list
and scrolling you can ask me all right
after so today's talk is going to be a
two-part talk we're gonna first start
off with some basics about SVG and
vector graphics talk about what is
what's happening in the web and what's
going on in native and react native the
second part I'm gonna share some stories
I have regarding animations with with
regard in lack native SVG so let's start
off so how many here are familiar with
SVG from the web Wow
I'm gonna quickly quickly cover it
before we're talking about SVG let's
talk about vector graphics why why do we
care about vector graphics so if you
care about complicated complicated
graphics complicated and visualizations
right now in our plane react native app
you have the view object which is you
can style it you can style the height
the width web border shadows it's pretty
pretty much it right pretty much limited
and in same in the sense of what the
designer is providing in his tools now
you can also go with images but that's
also limited you know we cannot control
the color of the images it won't scale
if you have to put put in an image for
every resolution and every screen size
if you want to do animations then forget
it you have to add an array of images
and pose a burden on their bundle size
and also very important most chances if
your designer is already using some sort
of vector graphics powered tools such as
Photoshop sketch and that's actually
those considerations applies for all
platform not only mobile web also so
that triggered this SVG in web 2 so what
is SVG stands for scalable vector
graphics so when a web standard for a
while since 1999 is pretty old and what
it is is actually XML based marker
graphic so we all love XML based markup
it's the parent node and the child node
HTML work works like that and the native
work like that
of course react and react native very
simple to use actually there are some
amazing stuff that you can do and we
just with SVG are know if you're
familiar with this graphics but that's
actually SVG so if we just hit up the
inspector for all of you
web developers so we can see that it's
compounded of thousands of elements and
you can start playing around with it see
what happens I really enjoy it
and there is a very good very good
documentation on the web and MDM if you
want to learn about SVG I really
recommend you check it out
it's very friendly written unlike no w3c
documentation in Euro if you if you
check it out
you are covered in terms of knowing SVG
so some basic example and in web a
little bit of web code we haven't seen a
web code here so just a little bit
you have the wrapping element of SVG it
has several attributes to name a few
width height all documented some basic
shapes shapes rect rectangle circle text
there is a positioning system which is a
kind of similar to the absolute
positioning system of CSS with the top
left corner or coordinate of zero zero
and as you go to the bottom into the
right you get positive x-axis and y-axis
accordingly this example you can see the
blue rectangle position on 2.5 + 2 / 5
coordinates one special element to note
and actually this is where all the magic
of SVG lies in is the patalamon so path
element what it is is actually it have
the D attribute which is a series of
commands and the originating point of M
and then source of commands of lines and
curves this is actually what enables to
draw anything on screen and this is very
very simple example there is a this line
it's originating some point two and two
and those are two certain ways to write
the curves it can get complicated really
really fast just see this naive looking
icon and this is what it takes to draw
it so a little bit about that later
moving to native so actually native
graphics already are built upon vector
graphics technique so and when even when
you just draw a default button it's it
it it draws into a canvas in in some
sort of vector graphic way it has to be
like this in order to support the
various resolutions and screen sizes
so an apple there is a core graphics and
on Android
the Android graphics just an example for
reviewing a Android native developers
might find this familiar if you want to
draw you want to bypass all the default
widgets you want to draw directly to the
screen so you extend the drawable class
and inside the draw method just as you
saw the series of commands of the DIA
tribute in the path and you see a series
of method invocations
to draw a path element over the course
of time there were some abstractions and
on top of it and there is a very famous
third-party third-party plugin in Apple
Kong Macao and on Android actually the
official SDK already have a new library
called vector drawable relatively new
which starts to looks like SVG in terms
of markup language and elements however
those are different elements not the SVG
so react native actually react native
ships with with the light with their
vector graphics library called out it's
not exactly SVG it uses different
different components but it's in react
native and it works across platform on
iOS you have to manually edit because it
pulls some sort of burden on there on
the bundle size another way to go and
actually the more commended way is to
use this this package called react
native SVG I'm going to talk about this
package from this point on some word
about this package it maintained by
these two main contributors magic is
might and Mikael send and what good
about it what beautiful where it is
confirmed exactly to the web standard of
SVG so if you know SVG from your
front-end days you know as we do in
react native and that's that's the point
of this this package it's already
included in a relative community you can
import it straight out of Expo
if you're using Expo it has rich
documentation and it even support touch
events which is a very important mobile
apps so this is the same example that we
saw in web this is in react native SVG
so as you can see it's the same thing
we're using the same elements we get the
same
result and with the same attributes
another neat thing that you can do with
SVG and this is done in react native SVG
is a some tricks you can do with text so
we are using the depth element which you
can draw elements in line without
without drawing them on the screen and
my unit the text path we can just refer
to the path alignment and make the text
flow across across that data element
so quick note about what's going on
under the hood so a regular native view
bridge as you well as you may know
consists of view view element on the
JavaScript side which maps to some
elements some objects on the native side
mainly the view manager in the view so
every view on the react native side maps
to a view on the native side however in
reality this video thinks works a little
bit differently so for every view or for
the element on the SVG it doesn't map to
review it maps to the shadow node we saw
on REMS the doc there is a shadow thread
so in the shadow knows it's a so it
manages the this the imperatively
calling of the canvas so basically it's
a class that what it does it draw into
one global canvas on screen using the
tab using the data limited that invokes
however SVG is a lot more than just
basic elements right we are we can do
rectangles and circles without without
SVG but one of the most popular uses to
of SVG is drawing charts so I hope now
you're all hypnotized and I can say
whatever I want now so when when talk
about charts the word d3 comes out
really fast so how many of you here are
aware of d3 yeah I was expecting that so
quickly d3 a JavaScript library for
dynamic data visualization it originally
made for the browser and it has browser
API is inside it so you couldn't use it
outside of the browser but as of version
4.0 they made some mode
separations and some of the modal's
modules just generally data so other
platforms outside of the browser such as
react native can now use d3 in order to
generate those long D attributes and use
them so we're going to see some example
we're going to show example regarding
game pie let's pick the pie example so
suppose we have like a demo data and
array with three items every item has a
number and a color so we start with a
wrapping SVG element and for each item
in the array we create a path element
and for the D attribute we are we are
using the d3 API so I'm not going to
dive too much deep into the d3 it has
like it's a reason for a different talk
I really recommend you to check out
Chile Woodstock from Lac Amsterdam I
think it was this year shiri talks about
how to code d3 with react and how it
behaved with the state and the component
really highly recommended so this is how
we we get the pi rendered that was like
very quickly an SVG overview so what I'm
going to talk about now is how to
animate those so those graphics are
really boring if they're not moving
on-screen right so let's talk about
animations so first the good news is we
get to use the animated API that we all
love hopefully so we all know that in
order to use animated we need to create
animated values those numerical values
that we can animate from one value to
another value we can even if we want we
can even animate string values by using
the interpolate and it even lets us add
some text to it which the style sheet
sometime uses so as long as it's parse
right on a JavaScript parser then it
works however what's what happens if we
have to animate between those values
that we saw that a lot that the pattern
emit is using this long values those
cannot
interpolated the interpolation API is
not supporting this long string values
or some other elements such as direct
which have all sort of attributes that
received objects so this in this example
an array to the two items in array and
what happened how can we animate that so
those are the challenges that I faced in
the last few months doing a SVG in react
native so I'm gonna cover like three use
cases in animation that hopefully will
give you some tools to overcome those
challenges so first let's talk about the
basics so a basic example we just want
to animate single value so no problem
there just want to show you that it does
work on a default case so we interpolate
we are animating the x value of direct
animated we are creating animated rect
and we interpolate the 0 and 1 to 5 and
to 20 and we push it to the x value so
that was the simple case but suppose we
want to animate the pie so in order to
animate the pies as I told you in the
pie consists of several slices each
slice is a very long and complicated D
attribute so how can we animate that so
what I did and I took a look in the d3
api's and I looked for some value that I
can increase all the time and very
single and single value that I can
increase over time that will let me
animate it so I found that multiplier of
the end angle in the pie the pie API
whatever that does and if I implicit the
pie gets get more percentage so this is
what I did in order to do that I'm using
a wrapping element called slice and
creating an animated component out of
that and the animated value is zero
point one one until two like we saw that
that's the multiplier and I'm going to
push that animated value into that
animated slice and sly
is very simple wrapper around the
pattern meant that we saw and I'm just
just gonna propagate and the animated
angle into the create by slice method
which now looks like that so it receives
a third parameter now it it will invoke
the d3 API with those with that
additional parameter this is how we get
the animation a third third use case so
that's a rect element in SVG and what I
did here I did some manipulations on
stroke there are various strokes and
attributes for SVG that you can
manipulate in order to get this this
effect with the underline and in one
state and the entire bottle drawn on the
next state so what we want to do and we
want to get from this state into that
state so we have to change few few
properties right so there are all stroke
properties so the first few properties
and no issues there they're just receive
single values the first receive
numerical values the second received a
string value so no problem interpolating
that however the stroke - array receives
an object and how can we how can we
animate the object so what I did here I
had to drop the declarative approach and
move to imperative approach which is
kind of reasonable hacking animations so
I'm not using it on the prop level of
the component instead I'm using another
API of animated value called listener
and using value XY animated value XY in
order to create two values instead of
one and for every tick in the animation
the listener gets called and i
imperatively using the set native props
on the ref element and this is how i
just change the value so those are so
this is another technique how to
overcome the interpolation challenge
so those were my three challenges in
animating react native SVG there might
be another challenges that I didn't
encounter but I get I got to a point
where I just randomly looked for cool
animations on web and within 10 to 15
minutes just threw it in my react native
app and using one of those tricks or
techniques so some of you may ask
whether those animations support uses
native drivers so we all strive to to
move all the heavy lifting of animations
from the Java scripts right into the
native side right so so there the bad
news is bless you the bad news is it's
not it's not supported yet however it is
it is very much working progress so if
you can check out this work and inside
the repository of react native SVG you
can see already a walk in example itself
done in a different branch but it's a
working example of animation on an erect
weight guess what he's narrative rival
true if you can see it so there is hope
you can check out those examples in the
github repo that I made for this talk
and hopefully you saw some cool tricks
that will let you use react native and
SVG and what's important is you can just
keep you can get leverage or knowledge
or already existing knowledge from web
regarding SVG inside the react native
app thank you that's my talk
[Applause]